the spirit proceeds from the father it
does not mean the spirit is a separate
person from the
father does the father proceed from the
father no so then the spirit is not the
father the spirit is the father so the
father proceeds from the
father
oh it's
God is
[Music]
God all right so want to start with your
question again yeah yeah so um it's uh
yeah pleasure to be a to speak to God
logic I'm here today kind of missed my
chance last week so I wasn't able to
hang around um my question initially
over there was how you reconcile um
teaching people that God is more than
one person when when Jesus was asked
what the most important commandment was
he quoted Deuteronomy 6:4 which in the
Hebrews here Israel yehovah our god
Jehovah is Ahad then Mark 12:29 Jesus
says yeah here Israel the Lord our God
is one yeah now in Mark 4 when Jesus
being tempted by Satan and being offered
based to all the kings of the world if
Jesus Will Bow Down and Worship Him you
know Jesus replies from Deuteronomy 6:13
he says worship yahovah your God and
serve him only and so who did he say
that to to Satan when Satan tries to
tempt him yeah he says worship Jehovah
God and serve him only and um you know
in Deuteronomy 6:7 there's a fascinating
passage that after Moses gives this
commandment to Israel that Jehovah our
god Jehovah is one he says and you shall
recite this to your children and you
shall talk about them at the time of
your going on the road you're lying down
and the time of you're rising up and you
shall bind them as a sign on your hand
and there shall be as to you an emblem
before he rise I'm really struck how
Moses instructed the people that that
the narrative that Jehovah was one was
so simple that a mother could explain
that concept to her child
and my concern is that the Orthodox
church has grossly corrupted the simple
revelation of scripture that Jehovah God
is a single self and turned it created a
counterfeit Jesus where he has been
elevated onto the face of God in direct
opposition to what yahovah said say you
have no other gods before my face so
that's essentially my opening gambut to
you D brother yeah okay
so to respond
to uh Mark 12:29 where Jesus quotes
Deuteronomy that's shama I would say
that uh I think that that actually
points to God being having a plurality
within his singular within his singular
uh Essence because as you quot it
correctly the word is aad which can be
used for absolutely singular but also
can be used for a compound one uh in
Genesis chapter 2: 24 it says that a man
this is why a man should leave his
mother mother and his father and be
joined to his wife and the two shall
become one aod flesh now obviously this
is showing a compound Unity with using
the word aad using the word one it's the
same thing that's being used in
Deuteronomy 6:4 where it says here o
Israel the Lord Our God the Lord is aad
one so I so I wouldn't say that
Deuteronomy 6:4 automatically shows a
plurality Within in God's nature I would
show I would say that we have Genesis
before Deuteronomy and then we have
Deuteronomy that shows us explicitly
that God has a plurality within his
nature which then we can conclude that
Deuteronomy 64 Yahweh is a plural being
okay so so you you've told the audience
here that the Hebrew word aad can mean a
complex Unity or a compound one can you
show me any Hebrew biblical lexicon
that's ever been written in the the
history of the world when you look up
the word Ahad you were going to find the
definition compound Unity or composite
well I I think that this is I don't have
to quote a lexicon for you it's
important brother because biblical lexit
can I can I answer you just just
biblical lexicons just so you know give
us the definitions of words in the Bible
yes and no biblical he uh no Hebrew
lexicon no Greek Lexicon in fact no
English lexicon will ever Define the
word one for you to mean a composite
Unity
or a compound un okay so when Adam and
Eve are joined together and they become
one flesh are they one person or are
they two so what you find here the word
the noun flesh scripture tells us is
comprised of two separate things one man
and one woman joined together to make
one flesh what we find in one
Corinthians are are they one person no
so we are told the scripture tells us
that in the in the context of a man and
a woman coming together in marriage or
in one Cor 6:16 a man and prostitute
coming together that they are one flesh
so scripture tells us the word flesh
equates to two separate things one man
and one woman coming together yeah so
are they one person they're not one
person okay beautiful one in unity so do
you they're not tells us you just said
that they come together doesn't say they
come so you saying that you said that I
didn't say in unity you said that they
come together what does come together
what does what what does unity mean
there's different so if a man with the
prostitute are you telling me in 1
Corinthians 6:16 where they come
together and they form one flesh that
they are in unity they're United
yes and they are they United
physically very good so they're come
together okay so scripture tells us the
noun flesh is comprised of one man and
one woman you're repeating this no no no
just like the word Day comprises
scripture tells us of one morning and
one evening just as in one Corinthians
12 Paul teaches us that our body is made
up of many members Eyes Ears Nose feet
but they come together to form one body
the issue is ladies and gentlemen
nowhere in scripture is the noun Jehovah
God or Lord ever defined as one or more
things coming together to form any kind
of Union nobody said that but that's the
point but my point is this brother you
just you just talked for like a long
time man you got to let me talk the
example how long you going to talk just
this last sentence the example of one
man and one woman coming together to
form one flesh is irrelevant got
Deuteronomy 64 because nowhere in
scripture is the noun yahovah God or
Lord or God sorry yahovah Lord or God
ever defined as one or more things
coming together understood form one
other thing got you I I'll let you go
right after me okay so you said that
it's not togetherness um together is not
Unity but then we got to the conclusion
that together is Unity that's literally
what Unity is when things are together
that's what a Unity you shaking your
head no it depends what your definition
of unity is okay when you when you okay
when you when you unite something when
you unite something there's a
multiplicity of things that come joined
together is that correct okay so that's
what a Unity is that's what together is
so one flesh is one man one woman well
got you so are they when they when it
says one flesh they are actually it's a
it's a compound unity in the one flesh
is that correct it does not say compound
Unity I know it doesn't say that I'm
asking if that's what it is I'm not
going to add to scripture well you don't
you don't have to add okay you don't
have to add to scripture when it says
one flesh is it one person or two
persons two persons okay is does Adam
have his own flesh yes does Eve have her
own flesh are they two are these two
flesh come together yes how is it then
just one flesh because that's what
scripture tells us beautiful so you
understand even through scripture the
word aad can be used to show you a
compound Unity where one thing and
another thing come together and they're
United so wait wait pause I gave you
your turn I gave you your turn so I I I
like to cross-examine a bit just to make
my point so with that being said just
because the word aad or one is used
doesn't doesn't necessitate that it's an
absolute singular thing okay when I show
when I showed you where Adam and Eve it
says they're aod one flesh they're not
they're not they're not one person as
you admitted they're two but they're
joined together so Yahweh is a one he's
one God One Singular Divine ultimate
entity that has multiple persons within
his Essence Father Son and Holy Spirit
are united in the essence of God and
therefore God is he one okay so guys you
got to listen really carefully what he's
saying he's conflating the word one with
the word
flesh tell not because you see we know
that one flesh in in relation to a man
and a woman you have two people yeah the
same example in terms of one day
comprises of one morning and one evening
so we know one day is 24hour period the
word one doesn't denote any form of
complex Unity or complexity or
compound it is the word one yeah that
tells us there is one of something so
two days tells us there are two lots of
24 hours if there are two flesh or two
couples we know there are four adults
involved
yeah your argument has no founding and
more importantly but you said Adam and
Eve are their own individual flesh but
the point is we know that Jehovah God
has defined the Word Flesh in scripture
as comprising of two adults no I'm sorry
that's not the word now the noun the
word the word flesh equals one man and
one woman no it doesn't no it doesn't
bro so what look I'm going show you I'm
going show you I'm going show you what
the word flesh means and you're going to
see that it entails man and woman you're
not going to see that but what you're
going to see is the word flesh human
Humanity your your body your pH physical
nature or whatever or carnal nature
you're not going to see man and woman
but unless you're talking about the
context where the man and woman come
together and unite as one flesh so
scripture defines us it's talking about
bodies The Word Flesh in scripture
either a man and a woman coming together
and marry in marriage or a man and a
prostitute when they come to together
that that Union is called flesh yeah
nowhere in scripture will you find
Jehovah the name of the almighty God the
noun Elohim or God or Adonai or Lord you
will never find scripture defining that
word as two or more things coming
together to form a godhead you will
never read Jehovah the Father the Son
and the Spirit come together to join one
God never happens anywhere in scripture
this argument has zero bounds can I no
grounds at all can I can I see the
reason you won't find that in scripture
is because we also believe God is
absolutely one the Trinity is in are
coming together of three persons the
three persons come from the father by
the two persons come from the father by
Nature by intellect and valtion so this
idea that you're trying to posit that
you're arguing against son can you
explain to me how like metaphysically
genu demonstrate to me that the three
persons negate the Oneness of
God okay so multiple times in scripture
it's not ask you
yeah multiple times in scripture Jehovah
describes himself as a single self now
the clue there when God speak say that
again okay when you he that God speaks
in the first person and says myself I
did this or is referred to using third
person singular pronoun such as himself
we all know that the word self myself is
referring to a single person there were
not three selves in a single self are
there ladies and gentlemen now Jehovah
God is referred to using first person
single pronouns 20,000 times in
scripture how many times do he use
plural this is very very simple how many
times does he use plural comp how many
times does he use we and our and us a
few times it's surr so does that does
that entail that Yahweh is now
multi-person no okay so when when Yahweh
uses singular pronouns like myself me or
I that automatically means that he's
absolutely One Singular person but when
he uses us we and our it doesn't mean
that he's plural persons come on
brothers and sisters look in any in all
your come on
now okay you might laugh at me yeah if
you were going to stake your life on a
piece of information that you believe
was true or false if you have 20,000
Witnesses yeah that proved one thing
that God is a single self and you have
literally four or five instances where
in scripture Jehovah God speaks using
whe hour are you going to place your
Eternal Destiny on three or four verses
or 20,000 verses are you going to trust
Yeshua your Messiah the anointed one of
Jehovah God or are you going to trust a
bunch
of crazy individuals who
manipulated the doctrinal Creeds of the
Christian
faith hundreds of years it's not a
fallacy Pro beyond beond all but you
still hav just but I'm sorry my friend
you have not broken down how when God
says Jehovah says that I or myself did
this or you know me that that
automatically means he's one person but
when he says us we and our that doesn't
mean that he's has a plurality of
persons can you break that down please
yeah I can do so my answer is this in
scripture we allow the clear and
majority passages to interpret the
minority of ambiguous passages brother
so I'm clearly not going to deny there
is the word our and we in a handful of
passages but it would be foolish
wouldn't it to allow those passages to
supersede the clear and unambiguous
testimony of scripture well okay I I I
like what you said there but this is
what I would suggest to you that you
don't eliminate the AL the other side
cuz you're you're you're too hard on one
side you're you you see the you know the
the ey the singular pronouns and you
you're resting on that that God is
absolutely singular when it comes to
personhood but IGN but disregarding the
parts where he says he we and us and our
he using plural how many are there would
you admit that
sure sure but this is my point this is
my point yes there are not as many uh uh
plural pronouns that God uses as when it
comes to singular pronouns but you can't
negate them so if you're going to no but
you are you're say you're saying that
there's only sing he's only a singular
person because he uses singular pronouns
but but rejecting that he's plural when
he uses plural pronouns you saying the
opposite no I'm saying he's both saying
his both I'm saying that he's singular
in his Essence plural in his personhood
guys in Hebrews 613 so for me my
my theology works with the scripture
with you you're contradicting it you you
tell people your theology works with the
scripture but brother it doesn't it rips
apart the Integrity of scripture in
Hebrews 6:13 listen to what the writer
of Hebrews testifies for when God
whens made a promise to Abraham he just
went to Hebrews since he had no one
greater to swear by swore by himself
ladies and gentlemen if God swore by
himself how many selves is that how many
selves is Jehovah how many s so if you
don't but he's asking about he's asking
about we don't believe God is three SS
you believe God is three persons one how
many persons how many how many
cells is in one person brother how many
Souls there's one self because there one
one self because there's one Divine
Essence there's one is
this well the thing is so I just showed
you that in Hebrews in Hebrews 6
yeah so there's one will in the Trinity
all actions are done by father Son and
Holy Spirit unitedly there's not um
there's not a different will of the
father and the son as Christ says I do
all the things I see my father doing
because they have the same will they do
all the same I am work brother they do
they Christ and the Incarnation has two
Natures also have a human will the same
way because there's one nature in the
Trinity there's one will when Christ is
a human and divine nature he must go
have two Wills yeah understand okay so
brother brother here is is just raised a
lot of points he's raised that that
Yeshua Jesus has got two Natures he said
that the father Son and the Holy Spirit
have one will what I was just getting to
in in a simple sense is that yahovah God
is spoken of throughout scriptures
having a single self now in 1
Corinthians 2:11 yeah Paul is talking he
teaches about the spirit that is in a
man and just another very simple example
of how the followers of Yeshua believe
the father God is a single self and in
Hebrews 21 father God is a single self
beautiful yeah is is a single self amen
you know the problem is here is you
don't you need to understand antomy this
idea that there are opposites in God
that are true at the same time you're
sacrificing the Oneness for the
plurality but yet both can be preserved
exactly brother there can be both both
it's both and not either or see you see
when Jesus said the most important
Comm Hebrews worship you yeah we can do
brother the most important commandment
is wait you about to say it God sorry
brother you just broke down another
Point let let me let me engage I asking
I was asking your brother there so
talking about this these three wheels
not United so one will United three
persons whatever in 1 Corinthians 2:11
yeah um Paul says this for who among men
knows the things of a man except the
spirit of the man that is in him yeah
thus so no one knows the things of God
except the spirit of God so I Pros to
you all yeah my spirit is no more a
distinct person than me than the spirit
of Jehovah God is a distinct person than
Jehovah oh man you're you're just like
you're Jehovah that's crazy that is okay
so my brother here God logic has a
spirit according to Paul yeah and Paul
says no one knows the mind of God logic
this fine gentleman other than his
spirit and then Paul from Paul comp Paul
myself you to Jehovah God cuz he says
Jehovah God has one spirit and that
spirit is Jehovah they are
indistinguishable they are not separate
persons they are one we agree but the
thing is here good do you believe the
spirit of God is a separate person
distinct yestin so there are two persons
let them resp thing is okay look firstly
you've just gone to a verse where it
talks about the spirit of God and you
haven't bother to ask the question
that's really relevant here is why do we
believe the holy spirit is a third
person you're just going to a verse and
saying well look is what I said why
don't you ask us where do we get the
idea from because when I go okay first
off I ask you a question right did you
come from your
mother yes okay do you share her nature
yes are you is she a person yes are you
a person because she's a
person suppose yes and you are human
because she's human yes and you good to
proceed or to come forth from something
means you are not that thing you have
come out of it yeah okay so when the
Holy spiritum it comes forth from the
father in John 15:26 and is sent by the
son
and you agreed that if it comes for it
shares a n shot and if the father is a
person saying your mother's it's a
person so the Holy Spirit no hold on
hold on hold on so the Holy Spirit
proceeds from the Father which he
admitted if you proceed forth from you
are not that thing so the holy spirit is
not the father he proceeds from the
father and he aditt that if he comes
forth he shares his nature and he's a
person so what does that mean he has
he's a person with the divine nature
John
the definition of a self-licking
lollipop like a little 5-year-old child
he's just gone to the shop he's gone in
he's brought himself a little lollipop
he's opened it and he's licking it and
you're applauding him why are you
applauding him what he's just spoken
there as pure philosophy I agreed with
the statements that he made none of
those statements are founded in
scripture what that's the point brothers
and sisters wait wait wait he he said he
said the spirit proceeds for from the
father that that's literally John 15 26
okay guys and you agreed to the premises
so guys so you've gone back of
course the spirit proceeds from the
father it does not mean the spirit is a
separate person from the
father does the father proceed from the
father no so then the spirit is not the
father the spirit is the father so the
father proceeds from the
father oh the brain function is crazy
I'm so guys guys guys yeah well here's
here's an interesting question right cuz
there
is's guys listen listen so we've already
we've already confirmed so Paul says
explicitly that the spirit of God say
there no more a distinct person than
than than the father than your spirit is
of you these gentlemen are saying that
the Trinity teaches Jehovah God is a is
one what comprised of three who and
these three who's are three distinct
persons that directly contradict what
Paul teaches in 1 Corinthians 2:1 now
let me take you to Isaiah
no this guy over
here no no brother yeah yeah we got this
we're right we're here right now so and
I'm going to say okay I need just a few
seconds here there are some passages in
the New Testament that talks about the
holy spirit that can appear confusing
that is we must use the Hebrew Bible as
our foundation but it's not confusing to
us as trinitarians good well let me let
me let's look at what Jes let's look
what Isaiah says regarding the spirit of
Jehovah we got Isaiah and then and then
let's quickly look at what Jesus says
about the spirit of Jehovah so in Isaiah
40:3 we SE we see Isaiah posed a
rhetorical question he says who has
directed Jehovah's Spirit or taught him
as his counselor yeah so Isaiah is
speaking again of the spirit of Jehovah
as the spirit of Jehova Spirit just as
my spirit is my spirit not two distinct
persons now lastly thank you very much
okay lastly yeah lastly in um in
Matthew uh sorry also job job says the
spirit of God has made me and the breath
of Shai gives life to me
does not distinguish between the breath
ofah God and the spirit of Adon they are
one in the yeah amen
amen okay hold on stop stop the breath
and the spirit are not distinct persons
that's the same Spirit you're right but
we're talking about the okay look you
said you said you said let's go to the
Hebrew scriptures you brought up Isaiah
let's stay in Isaiah so we're talking
about the Holy Spirit check yeah yeah
yeah Isaiah 48 the father proceeds from
the father verse 15 it says say I even I
have spoken and called him I have
brought him and he will prosper in his
way who's
speaking uh I'll have to go to Isaiah 48
Isaiah 48 all look look look I I got you
I got you look verse 14 verse 14 one up
to 12 hold on all right all yeah here it
is listen to me oh Jacob and Israel whom
I called I am he I am the first and the
last right that's Jehovah speaking you
would agree okay my hand laid the
foundation of the Earth Earth my right
hand spread out the heavens when I call
to them they stand forth together
assemble all of you and listen who among
you who among them has degreed these
things the lord loves him he shall
perform his purpose on Babylon and his
arm shall be against the Chans God still
speaking right okay I I even I am he oh
I'm sorry I even I have spoken and
called him I have brought him and he
shall prosper in his ways still Jehovah
speaking draw near to
he this from the beginning I have not
spoken in Secrets do Jehovah
speaking we'll see what do you mean
we'll see what does it change the point
is ladies and gentlemen no not ladies
and gentlemen you ask me why okay so
here's the thing that I just want to
stop you asked me a question I didn't
okay I said I said you ask me who is
still speaking Yeah speaking Yeah so and
and what I said was um I'm not certain
if that still is Jehovah speaking
because we know in the book well first
of all I'm not Isaiah I've not studied
Isaiah 48 recently in depth but we know
throughout the prophets that the speaker
can change from the prophet to the
prophet speaking the first person of
Jehovah so so who so you wait wait do
you think that you think Isaiah is
saying draw near to me hear this I have
would a prophet not say from from the
beginning Prophet not say I even I have
spoken I have called him sorry brother
sorry of course a prophet would say that
I have called him yeah who did Isaiah
call sorry you know we we just drop to
this bit here you're saying you're
saying would a prophet say draw near
near to me and hear this I would say
absolutely a prophet would say there a
problem there's a problem Sol well
because it says thus the Lord CU it says
from the beginning I have not been in
secret as in if you read this entire
text guys every time what's the
point every single time I read this
anytime I say I I want you all to say it
together with me can you do that guys
you're playing to your audience you're
not making I'm going to I want you to do
I want you to do it with me can you do
that with me every time it says I just
want you to read with me okay so listen
to me oh Jacob and Israel whom I have
called so same person speaking everyone
yes I am he I am the first and the last
yeah and the last and my hand laid the
foundation of the earth and my right
hand spread out unto the heavens when I
call to them they stand forth together
assemble all of you and listen who among
them has declared these things the lord
loves him he shall perform his purpose
on Babylon and his arm shall be against
the calans I even I have spoken and
called him I have brought him and he
will prosper to his way stop there
there's God speaking I reckon that on on
this at I've got no issue with that
being okay continue he's still so God is
speaking so what does God say Okay draw
near to me and hear this from the
beginning I have not spoken in secret
uh-huh from the time it came to be I
have been there you hear that is that
God speaking okay now watch What God
Says and now he says this is Jehovah
speaking sorry stop stop for a second
this is what Jehovah says Adon and now
Adonai Yahweh Adonai Jehovah has sent me
and his and his Spirit okay
guys lollip let's get lollip ladies and
gentlemen no brother brother just let's
submit this point let's submit this
point if God is the one who's speaking
it says that god Jehovah says that
Jehovah sent me how can Jehovah be sent
if he's only one person but then wait
wait he says Jehovah says Jehovah sent
me and his spirit so Jehovah sent
Jehovah and his Spirit how are they the
same person did the father send himself
did the father send himself with his own
spirit so he sends himself himself so
ladies and gentlemen is the
principle that if you if you believe in
the authority of scripture and in
particular the New Testament as being
our guide yeah we've got to submit to
the testimony of Luke 24 and Acts
chapter 1 that tells us that after can
you answer the question I'm going to
answer the question you haven't every
single time give me a second every
single time any of us have brought up a
question this is really important Point
brother it's a really important point
you have to answer this direct every
single time any of these two people
brought you a question this is what
you've done I'm going to like do it in
real time you've done this so what you
need to understand everybody is that you
need to answer their question this is a
very simple question it's a yes or no
did the father send himself no's the
father proceed okay guys this text my
start point is an illegitimate proof
text to discuss the nature of the father
and the nature of Yeshua and I'll tell
you why okay in Luke 24 we are given two
witnesses that after the resurrection of
Jesus he spent 40 days teaching his
disciples which specific passages in the
law of Moses the prophets and the Psalms
were about him and it even says he
supernaturally opened their mind so he
could understand the scriptures the
point is gentlemen this passage is never
quoted in the New Testament as speaking
about Jesus nor is it used to discuss
the nature of God in the New Testament
you have plucked this verse from
obscurity
and you've elevated it into the position
of a false god and by it you are trying
to deceiving people the point ladies and
gentlemen because this scripture is
never used by Jesus it's never used by
Paul or Peter ever how can you say it's
irrelevant how can you say because you
say look if you're say look
exactly you you you saying look wait
wait no no let's not play that game look
if you're saying that Jesus never brings
the up the New Testament never quotes
this as talking about Jesus Bears no
relevance to our question to you no no
it does to question it's not it's not a
Messianic prop was your no no was your
you're you brought up about the spirit
being a distinct person so we're talking
about the spirit it says here that
Yahweh sent Yahweh and his spirit and so
my point was gentlemen so is yahwe the
same as his Spirit yes Yahweh and his
Spirit are the same thing in the
distinguishable are they the same person
they are no the spirit is not a person
okay see see see you're so close You're
So when you say no no we'll get there
we'll get there
next your spirit wait wait hold on a
second hold on a second you're you're so
close because you acknowledge that the
spirit is not distinguished from Yahweh
in his being you acknowledge that but
however where you mess up well yeah of
course amen hallelujah but where you
where you slip is where you say no but
he's not a person the spirit is not a
person because you agreed earlier you
said that when someone comes forth from
a person they are a person I agree to
your questions I answer them yeah but
your definitions don't apply to Jehovah
God because in 1 Corinthians 2:1 Paul
tells you doesn't follow it does brother
look you you've made some you've made
some you've made something up yeah
I okay I'm using
scripture because I come forth from my
mother SC because because I come forth
from my mother yeah and I'm a separate
person from my
mother you're now saying that this
because of one verse in John from that
the spirit comes forth from the Father
the the spirit is separate person what
I'm
saying
interpretation contradicts the multiple
clear T Testament now can I just I just
want to just do one and then you go St
no stay here I am this is about Jesus no
it's not about Jesus right now we're
talking about the spirit I'm going to
talk about what Jesus says the look I'm
just asking you right here
who sends guys who sends the spirit
according to this verse the father sends
the spirit okay is the Father the
spirit this
okay where we go from
here we go
here stuck stuck in the middle of
nowhere close
to so there is a passage in
Isaiah which is which is spoken about in
Revelation a number of times brother
where it talks about the seven spirits
of Jehovah yeah and there is the
prophetic statement that the root of
Jesse will rise up and the spirit of
Jehovah will be on him it talks about
seven distinct spirits of the father
Spirit of wisdom the spirit of knowledge
the Spirit of Courage the spirit of
Might the spirit of understanding the
spirit of godliness and the spirit of
the fear of the Lord Jehovah promised in
the book of Isaiah and you're aware of
this that he would raise up a human
being a servant upon whom he would place
his Spirit the point is scripture
teaches us ladies and gentlemen that
there is the spirit of yahovah as in his
Spirit just like your spirit but there
is also the seven spirits of Jehovah God
now we read in the Book of Revelation is
the spirit of Jehovah separate from the
seven spirits yes they're the same thing
man brother brother so look in the Book
of Revelation okay so in the Book of
Revelation we are taught that the Risen
and the see you all looking with
surprised faces CU you never would have
read Isaiah 11 this is heresy it's what
heresy Isaiah 11 brother because you
know it and it is a fascinating passage
it talks about the seven spirits of
Jehovah what does that have to do with
my question because the resurrected
Jesus declares that he has been given
authority over the seven spirits of
Jehovah at his resurrection that's not
what he says yes it is this is I am the
one who holds who has who who has
control over the seven spirits of yah
that is what Jesus is talking about when
he's talking about what he's going to
send after he's been resurrected this is
what this this is the point what was my
question is Jehovah sending his Spirit
no my question was is is the Father the
spirit that he sent yeah so the the
father and the spirit in one sense are
indistinguishable yeah they are one and
the same the spirit of yahovah is not a
distinct person from the father
according to the prophets according to
Paul according to Yeshua I got you look
look this is my this this is my question
with what you just said you said in one
sense the spirit is indistinguishable
from the father Amen in what way are
they distinguishable cuz you said he's
not the okay so here's the question
again is the Father the
spirit yes so the Holy Father proceed I
got tell so in Matthew so the father
proceed wait so if the father is the
spirit then the father sent this father
right no no say it the father sent the
father that's what that's what that's
that's what your theology leads to no it
doesn't because there are some passages
in scripture where the language is
slightly confusing MTH this is not
confusing in Matthew 12 it's not
confusing this confusing to anybody is
the is the Father the spirit no does the
father send the spirit are they distinct
persons can you be the same person you
sent no that's not confusing okay so
Isaiah says this so you all saying you
all agreeing with God logic yet in
Isaiah 4012 this is what Isaiah says who
has directed Jehovah's spirit it's a
rhetorical question no one directs
Jehovah's spirit because it is the
spirit of Jehovah it is the spirit of
God look in Matthew 12 just listen
listen to this
please explicitly teaches that the
titles the spirit of the God yeah the
spirit and the Holy Spirit are all
interchangeable for the spirit of
Jehovah talking of a separate person
wait wait wait yeah St about separate
person we understand that the spirit has
all these different titles we all
understand this right the spirit has
different titles is one of the titles of
the Spirit
father okay so the father is distinct
from the spirit
correct wa that doesn't make sense okay
get me get me out of
here I'm done I'm done I'm done I want
to leave I want to leave I want to leave
it's not
okay could you read out 1 Corinthians 11
can I just ask you a quick question can
I ask can I just can I just read this
again please guys let's listen to what
Paul says cuz you're all mocking me for
saying the spirit Jehovah God Is Not A
distinct person from Jehovah to listen
to what Paul says this is what Paul says
all right we got we got to write this up
soon for who among men knows the things
of a man except the spirit of the man
that is in him that's right yeah okay
happy that thus no one knows the things
of the God except the spirit of the God
why are you applying a different rule to
what Paul says here to and accept what
these gentlemen are teaching you are
directly cont that's not contradiction
do you know can you demonstrate the p
and not P
here ofic number one just thing is you
just did something crazy you just
appealed to logic every time he's
appealed to logic philosoph philosophy
oh no no before you brain man function
let me finish pleas okay before your
brain man functions let me finish he
gave you a syllogism which is logic you
said well that doesn't really make sense
cuz there's times in scripture where
this is that but he used logic which you
can't
you just appealed and said it's a wo wo
you just appealed and said it's a
contradiction the problem with it I
please okay it's very very clear all of
this has been clear all of this is very
clear okay I'm going to ask I'm going to
do the we're going to wrap up too we got
I need to cook a Muslim yeah the thing
that's very clear is this yeh sends his
Spirit yeh in the sense of essence is
the same the father from the spirit are
the same in essence that's why there's
one God that's very easy we can for this
unity and
distinction however the father did not
send himself neither did the father die
on the cross he proed from the father
did not Eon from himself that is the
Greek word in John 15:26 scripture
scripture in John it says that the
spirit proceeds from come comes out my
question was does anything else proceed
from the father not an emanation it's a
ession obession you tell me brother
nothing nothing else so this means that
the holy spirit is not just God's power
cuz God's power doesn't proceed from
himself otherwise there was a period
where he didn't have his power but
eternally the Holy Spirit proceeds from
the Father the same way that the son is
begotten from the father can I just
encourage you all to do a study on the
seven spirits of yahovah that's that's a
good study very great study good study
guys guys look
energies that GRE is the Divine energies
of God we can talk about that in Exodus
33 we can go that we canat about let's
just
go got we got to wrap up we got guys
guys seriously on a serious note we got
to wrap up I need
to you can no do you want to say
something last or you want to suggest a
stud you said I am very grateful for
speaking to God logic um he passionate
man you work very hard um and uh I'm
really grateful to have the opportunity
to speak to you
um I do hope that maybe off camera
clearly not now cuz you're heading back
but um I don't need to do stuff on
camera you know we next time I'm out
here I'll be out here soon we can maybe
your dude can give me a number I could
come on your channel but even just doing
stuff off channel so there isn't a
requirement to have to win an argument
but we can just chat and that would be
that would be cool because I know you
study the scriptures a lot um and uh
yeah but I'll just encourage you all
just do a word study on the seven
spirits of Jehovah and look at how Jus
when he is elevated to his position as
high priest Jehovah God gives him
authority over the seven spirits for the
edification and building up of the
church I believe those Spirits are
something slightly distinct from the
spirit of Jehovah we agree yeah agree
yeah so yeah distinct from the Divine
Essence yep all right guys good wrap up
good conversation let's go ahead and
move on to see what else we can get
today all right all right God bless you
Jesus Christ be with you that's right
Jesus Christ is Lord pris is
king oh my God logic
[Music]